all right Albert Breer was part of our
coverage all year long he's with the mm
QB and he joins us here after Super Bowl
52 on the Rich Eisen show how are you
doing Albert I'm doing well let's get
right to it what happened with Malcolm
Butler best you can tell what's going on
well a lot of there's been a lot of
noise over the last year you have to
remember last year he was a restricted
free agent and so he was able to go and
ascertain what his market value would
have been and at one point it looked
like he's been betrayed in the New
Orleans Saints so when that deal fell
through you know at that point Malcolm
had a very real idea of how much money
the Patriots were keeping him from by
not trading him there and certainly we
saw some bumps during training camp we
saw a couple bumps during the early
parts of the regular season and it
seemed like this has gotten into
Malcolm's head that said he played over
1,000 snaps in the regular season on
defense he was third on on the team
among defensive snaps among defensive
players and snaps played he played a
hundred percent of the snaps in the game
against Tennessee he played a hundred
percent of the snaps that game against
Jacksonville and this is just bizarre I
mean they they they rolled you know I -
Ron Harmon off the bench
Jordan Richards off the bench Johnson
bad MOC off the bench seven defensive
backs until it'll play significant snaps
and he wasn't one of them so clearly
something happened here and you know I
think we'll all be scrambling to figure
out what but this just doesn't happen
you know especially in a game where
you're getting torched the way the
Patriots were getting torched to leave a
a former all-pro on the bench like that
which is the dog yeah and then you know
obviously there's the Brandon browner
Instagram where he said that a locker
room was divided pregame meaning he must
have spoken to somebody who he used to
play with in New England that's
currently there and what could that have
possibly
because everyone is talking about that
as to who liked it including Dante
Hightower who's on IR sure and you know
it's interesting if you guys go back and
look you know selcuk spoken at Ohio
State's coach and clinic last spring and
I can remember
Urban Meyer getting up there introducing
Belichick and he was talking about
lessons at Belichick had given him and
you know one of the things that that
urban said was that bill said to him you
know I've just kind of come to the point
my in my life at my age where I don't
want to coach players I don't like
anymore I want guys who are on board
with what we're doing here
and it was interesting to hear that at
the time to kind of take that and say
well is that what Jamie Collins being
traded was about is that what Chandler
Jones being traded was about and felt
has never been afraid to make bold
decisions but it seems more often over
the last three or four years they've
made more decisions based on guys going
off the reservation just even a little
bit and they've been a little less
tolerant of that that sort of thing and
so you know that's why again ultra
talented players like Collins and Jones
are gone and you'd have to think that it
certainly played a role and why Malcom
Butler wasn't on the field last night
you know and because we have evidence
that it's affected the relationship over
the last year I think you certainly see
how Belichick kind of making the
standard angle on them a little more
stringent and even it was before about
being with the program and I could have
affected the way they handled Buffalo
this year so I'll ask you the poll
question that was inspired by the
browner Instagram go for Chris Brockman
ask him what's on our on our app Apple
App Store Google Play and we as well
obviously on our twitter handle
advertising show
yeah Albert do you think Malcolm
Butler's benching affected the Patriots
ability to win the Super Bowl I mean
look you know I again I'm not saying
Malcolm Butler would of
would have made all the difference in
the world but they couldn't get a stop
you know they couldn't get a stop when
they needed to get a stop and they were
having real problems covering you know
Nelson Aguilar and Al Shean Jeffrey and
Torrey Smith and you know sitting right
there they've got your first-team
all-pro on the on the bench and I I'm
just telling you like I don't I don't
think were to change everything I don't
think that this you know he would have
transformed them defensively but you
know I certainly think that Malcom
Butler could have helped them get the
one stop they needed and that's really
what last night's game came down to is
who was going to make it defensive fly
at the end it was Brandon Graham making
the defensive play to turn the game
Malcolm Butler's shown in the past he's
capable being that player and I think
him being on the field would have given
the Patriots a better chance of getting
the one stuff thinking well earlier this
hour Albert we played two soundbite of
Rob Gronkowski after the game making it
seem like it's entirely possible he
played his last down in the NFL what do
you think about that 10-15 years ago
that would have been an absolute stunner
and now not so much
I mean we're just we're seeing this with
football players a little bit more guys
have been dinged up a lot just kind of
come in to the determination that you
know I want to preserve my quality of
life when I'm 50 60 70 years old I'm not
willing to sacrifice that we saw Patrick
Wilson Louis we saw with Calvin Johnson
where were those guys have been through
a lot physically and just kind of came
to the determination I just don't want
to put myself through this anymore
listen Bronks been very responsible with
his money I'm sure you guys have heard
this story before but he basically lives
off of his endorsement money and he's
put away the money that he's made off of
football and so he's done well there
certainly because of his personality and
who he is I think he'd have a chance to
make money outside of football whenever
he's done and so you know I think it you
know you look at a guy who had to had
another concussion during the playoffs
who's had the back issues which don't go
away
and who's made a lot of money to take
care of his money and you didn't
certainly see whether this is something
you think about now I think one thing we
have to remember is that it's the end of
a long season and a lot of times these
are the wrong time to ask guys about
those sorts of things because you know
they're beat up and obviously in this
circumstance tonics coming off of a
really tough loss and so we'll probably
get a more coherent answer from him if
we ask him in three or four weeks but
you know certainly you can see you know
guys thinking about this and if playing
into a larger trend with football
players where you know when guys have
the choice to walk away and preserve the
quality of life that they'll have in 20
or 30 years seems like now they're more
apt to take that that opportunity and
they would have been maybe a couple
decades a couple more minutes here with
Albert Brewer from mmm QB dot-com
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
Nick Foles future we discussed it
earlier on this show - I'd like to ask
you if you think that he's going to be
on the Eagles next year or we should
throw him into the mix with Kirk Cousins
and others that are out there as a
veteran that might wind up in spots that
currently might draft a quarterback in a
couple of months from now what do you
think because maybe that's the first
year I can remember at least where
supply me out out way demand at
quarterback you look at who could be out
there now where are simply drew Brees to
be back in New Orleans but he can be a
free agent if he wants to be Kirk
Cousins will be out there you've got the
three guys in Minnesota and keenum and
Bridgewater of Bradford all of them are
free agents and you throw bowls
potentially into the mix with all the
rookies as well with Baker Mayfield and
Josh down with Josh Rosen sand Arnold it
makes you question to some degree how
much the Eagles are gonna be able to get
for him and how other teams are gonna
look at the playoff front that he made
now I'll say this Nick Foles didn't look
like a quarterback is that hot he looks
like a different quarterback in the
playoffs he look like a quarterback
who's grown up the question is whether
or not that sustainable and I think the
egos willingness to move Nick Foles
is going to come
100% to the return because o because
Carson Wentz is coming back off of multi
ligament you know me me tear to me it's
if there's real value in keeping him in
the roster and and going with him
through OTAs the only was history
training he happened so I think it's one
of those situations where it makes sense
for them to hold on and they close this
is why you invest in a backup
quarterback the way they've invested in
a backup quarterback and you know I
think they'll listen to other teams
offers my understanding is they will
listen to other teams offers for them I
just think it's gonna take something big
for the thing to get them to move on
from what's a pretty valuable insurance
bomb there's no question I mean Steve
Smith on our coverage this week said
there's no way whence is coming back on
time not a chance
that is an weekend it's a bad I said
like the reason multi multi ligament
tears it's not just may CL it's an LCL
to and I'm most learners I talk to them
have been through that it can be a
little complicated and so you know I
mean week one again III know that's his
goal but you know it's it if you're not
gonna know for sure until you get to
July or August
you know then having an insurance policy
like Nick Foles is bad
alright so then last one for you here
Albert so McDaniels will be introduced
as the next coach of the Colts and
Patricia the next coach of the Lions
when next couple days what do you think
yeah so my end of all my understanding
is that Josh was going to accept the job
with the Colts today officially and then
they were gonna have a press conference
on Wednesday at least that was the that
was the plan and not Patricia obviously
we've seen some of the moves the Lions
have made that's a fait accompli so
whether that's today or tomorrow he'll
accept that job and he'll be introduced
at some point this week and then I think
the other piece that could move is a
special teams coordinator in New England
Joe Joe to his contract is up he let his
contract laughs and I think there's a
chance that he joined
josh mcdaniels in indianapolis what you
mean bill belichick will be losing all
three of his coordinators and then and
then i think that what will be
interesting that is to see if bill
brings some experienced coaches onto his
staff does he try to bring Scottie
O'Brien back to be the special teams
coordinator he worked with Bill on
Cleveland and again in New England does
he go get Greg Schiano from Ohio State
to be maybe assistant head coach
linebackers to help Brian floors as he
becomes the offensive coordinator there
are a lot of moving pieces here and a
lot for the Patriots to work out you
know offer Brady and Belichick that's
right I thought that was my next that
was my next question is is lastly when
does that meeting of the minds take
place what does that happen with I think
it has to happen soon you know and and
I'll say this for Robert he's always
been good in these situations fast he's
always been able to define common ground
this is complicated you know I I think
the third rail for both the Kraft family
and Belichick is ownership involving
itself in personnel decisions obviously
the Garofalo trade is something that's
been a subject of discussion on that and
Jonathan Kraft came out earlier this
week and said that Brady had earned the
right to dictate his own exit from the
Patriots and that again his ownership
speaking on football personnel decisions
so I think they kind of work that stuff
out they've also got to work out the
role of Alex Guerrero within the team
and that's something that I think is
difficult to approach Brady on to
because you know this is incredibly
valuable for him for his business for
the next 20 or 25 years Deb Alex as part
of the team and you know III think if
you're Brady and they come to you and
they tell you to put a lid on you're
gonna say I've taken less money I've
done everything you've ever asked of me
I've been the ultimate team player I've
enabled your entire program and I just
want to do this little thing to try to
set up my business for the next 20 years
and you telling me del so I think that
one's complicated too there's just a lot
to work out there you know obviously
sets Wickersham there's a lot of truth
in what he wrote about a month and a
half
there's a lot to work out great stuff
Albert great stuff as always we'll chat
soon
appreciate the call you got that's
Albert freer the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience